through several important aspects of
transcriptomic data so we have the
platform leap do you have the access to
the platform already so if you go to
server that T - buy all that info you'll
be able to see the areas of analysis and
today we're gonna cover transcriptomics
which is circled in red and then data
mining and utilities so the idea here is
that you can process data prepare it for
data mining then do data mining and then
afterwards you'll be able to do
annotation first of all processing of
next generation sequencing data inside
each one of those sections you will see
a pipeline builder in the pipeline
builder we'll go through this in detail
but I'm just giving an overview right
now what we're going to cover so we will
see how to take raw next-generation
sequencing reads how to prepare them in
terms of trimming technical sequences
and removing PCR duplicates and then how
to detect some patterns differences in
the samples that we have data for the
next step we will go through
unsupervised and supervised analysis of
that data so we'll learn things like
principal component analysis in
clustering and then supervised is when
you build a model that can tell you
something about the new sample that you
want to classify finally after we got
the results we will do feature selection
so we will end up having a smaller
number of genes and then we need to
understand what do those genes do so we
can annotate those genes or we can use J
differential gene expression in order to
have gene set enrichment so what
pathways are those genes in and what
pathways are more enriched than others
now before we jump into the data a few
words about why we're doing this and
what data set are we going to be using
so we're gonna be using a cell line
a set that are taken from human tissues
and we're gonna be looking at breast
cancer so we have something like a
mammogram the mammogram is you know you
can detect areas that look like tumors
but the main question is okay what how
do we classify that right so what can we
assign that tumor as the source that the
source of that cancer and then we have a
number of methods to do that so one is
by looking visually where it came from
another one is immunohistochemistry and
finally now we have these molecular
subtypes which is what we're going to be
doing and here what we're trying to see
is how to use gene expression the levels
of gene expression to assign the tumor
to a specific class how can we use this
information so we can use this
information to diagnose and propose how
the the person can for example survive
so rate of survival or rate of
recurrence and there are already panels
like that used in their clinics Pam
fifty is one that we will refer to today
or paying fifty stands for 50 genes so
it's a panel made up of 50 genes and
based on their expression we can assign
a tumor to different subtypes and then
there are other ones on the market for
example encore encore type DX and based
on these we can make several clinical
decisions so we can make decisions about
how much tissue remove in surgery we can
determine whether radiotherapy is going
to be helpful or not we can also choose
different types of chemotherapy and then
today we have also this targeted therapy
class that takes all this information to
make a very precise prescription around
the target now the data set that we're
going to be doing this analysis with
today is actually an interesting study
they took 52 different cell lines so
they're all breast cancer cell lines
taken from the tumor and grown into
culture and then different drugs were
applied to these cell lines to see how
fast the division of the cell lines
stopped and then we have two data sets
so we have a data set which is profiles
of these cell lines so RNA seek of the
cells and we have GI 50 values so how
fast they die applying different drugs
now today we're just going to look at
the transcription data and try to use
that transcription data to classify the
samples now did you get this folder with
the data please no really
yes it was supposed to be on the website
if not we can give it to you now so
let's see if it's on the website
okay so on okay so you have this the
Buckshot phone yeah yeah you do have it
on the inner page right okay yeah yeah
it's got a download right yeah number
five
yeah yeah yes it's a zip file and if you
unzip it so this is just what you see on
the screen is the preview of the folders
that are inside right so you have the
presentation the input files the output
files etc so just to explain as an
example one of the files that you will
see there is this svl samples thatis
feel and it's under expression
quantification you have found
yeah yeah yeah it looks like the folder
is different actually in tensile test
different this is the wrestler yeah yeah
yeah let me give you this yeah so I can
give you signal to file and you can
share that and here I will give the file
real quick here that I'm here I won't
[Music]
I think what's the you know yes
a little bit big but you will get it
here shortly
so it's uh the files inside have both
the input files and the output files
fine
but just if you open it in my text Wow
okay what's inside I'll just explain
briefly what those files are so we're
all clear I think you can start to
completion today we can while we're
waiting for him to get the final stuff
oh yeah yeah so the file should look
like this right yeah so what to explain
what this is this is the file is already
on the server and instead of downloading
and uploading all those fast queue files
we are using they're off ASCII files but
these are just reference links so the
system knows which folders to think from
so we don't need to do the upload that
the files came from the paper and
analyzing the he'll did you get the
files yeah we will
yeah right after this so I'm just giving
you all good background okay so you
downloaded do you Skype me back in man
yeah I'm just downloading it so just
made for two minutes please okay what
and what do you use to use Google
Hangouts or anything like that I mean
it's here I'm doing mr. myko USB it's
just a large Mouse it is it's taking
long jumper yeah that's
I will get through this something like
this dc9
send your dropbox link we can download
them
okay sorry for the delay here we've got
the files
yeah
No
what
you
okay so like an engine you are used on
that good you're not getting it
let me try it okay sorry if you want to
make this much stuff let's do this yeah
what what is that email I can try
popping yeah that's it yeah let's say
you know right it's not given a degree
you know see if you
what is that my GTA SA get genuine
tricky
you know
okay yeah it should be okay oh okay so
if you go over here you also should have
an account already right on the platform
so on the platform any section that you
go into will look approximately the same
you'll have a section to upload the
files and you'll have a section down
here to build the pipeline what do what
are these about buttons and what do they
represent
they are algorithms a lot of them are
public domain algorithms that you can
also run on Linux and or some of them
are some of them in various languages
but the important thing is that this
provides an interface that we don't have
to worry about installation we don't
have to worry about different
inconsistencies between versions and
packages and things like that we can
just learn the logical web molosser and
then the logic is cleaner we can then
think about how to implement this in a
different environment so for example the
files that you've got they will be
uploaded and then once they're uploaded
you'll be able to start the pipeline so
we will get to that just in a second
just in the meantime just to explain to
you what are you looking at right so
let's go back for a second to the
presentation to talk about our Macy and
so the bond over here is going to talk
about RNA seek some background about RNA
seek and then how to create our first
pipeline with the files ok let's start
from concept of next-generation
sequencing and we have genome just very
long sequence of nucleotides just
letters 80 GNC and we have some genes
here for example in aging BMC
then after transcription protests some
of these dreams are they became trance
treats
actually these are mRNAs so today we
will speak about mRNAs and some of the
genes can some of them are expressed and
some of them are not expressed in this
picture gene a and gene C are expressed
and win B is not expressed and what is
next generation sequencing is when we
cut transcripts to small pieces they are
called weeds and after that we read this
reads and then we map this reads to the
announcement streets to the known gene
positions some more detailed scheme
first million you can actually just for
our presentation some detailed scheme
first transcript are shattered to small
pieces then some adapters allocated to
these pieces some known sequences and
then PCR amplification is performed so
number of reads is increased and then
all these reads are read it by the
sequencer and and after that we have a
huge file format is fast queue so it's
just small pieces small pieces of
nucleotide sequences and what we gonna
do first we should protect this data as
I said we added some adapters oh what's
we added some adapter so we need to to
them remove with adapters and at the
next step we should remove PCR
duplicates just to improve quality of
our files and after that we huge map
this reads on on the set of non
transcripts however in this strategy we
won't consider reads which are mapped
actually two unknown positions so if we
want to look at unknown positions - we
can map this risk on the genome not on
the known gene set but on the genome and
then we can assemble this trans
transcriptome and then we can merge
these transcripts with non trans creats
and map them map the reads one more time
to these these transcripts so and then
we could quantify expression levels
let's see how it works in platform and I
think it will be easier to understand
just share
[Music]
okay let's create pipeline for Forex
expression quantification levels first
we should fill these forms we have fast
queue files our organism is Homo sapiens
we will use 38 version of the genome and
we have paired-end reads so we should
place p/e here and this one here after
that we can upload the files here we
tweak URL bulk upload actually you can
click add files and upload these huge
files but we will not waste time yeah
and where is it else yeah
then we go to input files expression
quantification and select samples dot
SPL load it and click define groups okay
here we see our samples each sample
actually presented as two files because
our reads is paired and so first ends
are in first file and second in the
second one and for this analysis we
don't have any group so we click here
until no groups and now we are ready to
build our pipeline so how we do it first
we should click on start okay so first
we should reprocess the
first we shoot trim adaptors and for
that we have a job called trim emetic so
just click on that safe and you see the
edge now so input data first we'll go to
this job after that we want to remove
some PCR duplicates so we click on PCR
clean what yeah if you want to remove so
now the data travels from we will see it
further
after some minutes now no groups now
down here you can see what traumatic
doesn't associative public dish I'm just
saying that for each button there is a
pop-up in the pocket you can read that
thing and now so now data travels from
start than 2/3 mimetic and then to PCR
clean so output of each note is to
travel still to the next ok then we need
to map these data on transcripts for
that we have job called bowtie to you
weekly save and after that we want to
create expression table and for that we
have job air see max table
yeah good question hello
yeah so for the PCR clean out right
Linton Sansa how are the duplicates
recognized mints should be and a half
some kind of barcode in the initial
reaction or is that not necessary we
will miss our cleaning effects the
result and it's actually improves
quality of analysis and it should be
done every time you work with my
question is much like how are the
duplicates recognized up here files yeah
I mean so what exactly is a PCR clean up
I thought the PCR duplicates I recognize
you're right yeah so how are they
recognized so they are specific you know
the that the PCR amplifies certain reads
many many times and certain recognizes
that amplification and reduces it to the
standard across all the sample just
substitute the histah kill procedure
there are some several methods of that
not so easy as you can think it's just
non-trivial procedure okay okay after
mapping we should select our C MAX
people which creates the expression
table and here we have options is just a
measure of the expression let us select
fpkm
and I will tell you what it what it is
in the next slides very safe and then we
go to the end save assign some name for
example step and there is a question
from the audience what there is a
question from the audience okay
I sniffing this is Sami from Nebraska I
have one question
I saw pure pure raw PowerPoint
presentations which is stored in the
website where you go to first offered
then cufflink then to bowtie why in this
case we are going directly to bowtie why
you is keeping Topher turned cuff link
in this particular case okay I will tell
you in one minute about it just wait one
minute and I will tell you consolation
and please don't click run pipeline now
because this pipeline actually works
some hours and days but it doesn't
matter why we are using Chrome for this
but I've loved being Safari for this
what can I reload post yeah so just to
explain here really quickly this
interface is going to be available for
you from the next 14 days after this
work and you can do the same stuff or do
something you know we want to do the
demonstration and kind of go quickly for
many different sections so we're not
going to run some of the pipeline's
but later on you'll have that
opportunity and the second consideration
around how long does it take to run a
pipeline so the bigger the number of
files the larger number of files and the
larger each file the longer it's going
to take these accounts are limited so
the more people use them the less
capacity you have individually and so
that's another consideration so I I have
already ran around this pipeline use it
and we can see how it looks after
running you will see three buttons
download pipeline output files and here
are our output flat files you
have them your folder workshop may
output files and then expression
quantification you are two needed files
so let's now return to the presentation
here's a basic pipeline we have just
created and as I said in this pipeline
we mapped our reads on known gene set
now mapping unfilled script maps
reads to the long gene set and we have
extended pipeline to handle situation
when we want to another analyzer unknown
position for that we have the same start
start trim emetic PCR clean and then we
map the data to the genome for that we
have a job I set to so these maps the
data to do you know then we go to the
cufflinks cufflinks assembles the genome
the transcriptome so it takes reads
mapped to the genome and try to
understand which regions of genome are
well powered on
so it's assembles in transcriptome
then cough merge merges these create a
transcript oh with known gene set and
then we we map a reads to this new
extended transcriptome and here is both
Harry - as we done through this time
so this pipeline handles some either
form some exons and it it it makes
possible working with unknown gene sets
but we will not look at this pipeline
today we will look on the basic pipeline
so I think I answered your question
about this pipeline and now let's
summarize something about a pipeline
grading scheme and I have some plus
tasks for youth hi hello hello
yep can you hear me yep just one
question everyone note this bar top part
I said all the same functions who went
to you Joe this profile and waiting to
use this hi start
I set Maps reads on the genome and
bowtie to t maps the reeds on the
transcriptome what I'm asking about over
just above the high start ah ok you can
use top hat too these are two
alternative algorithms and I've used hi
said to just for an example so you can
use top hat too so but now what you can
actually try and do in our exercise you
go to the platform can you try and
create your own pipeline without
following direction so what we want to
show and you can click on the section
name read about what the section does
can just create some random pipe
language do anything yeah so if looking
at the interface and you create some
kind of a pipeline based on what we just
did and and another consideration when
you're making this pipeline is that you
can fix mistakes so if you go to
any section so again remember that you
can only start building the pipeline
after you specify your input files but
you already have input file so you
should know how to do this and so you
can add either a bulk well yeah right
yeah so you just tell you have to
specify for this pipeline which files
it's going to be using so if you have an
s VL with ready files on the system
there's no upload but for example now
let's go and delete this let me show an
alternative way so like I showed you
before the svl files they contain links
right so let's open this SPL file again
and see what's inside so what is inside
his file many different links so I can
take an individual link let's say I want
to create a pipeline and I just want to
add here a single fast queue file so
this pipeline will only have one pair
and sample so now if I go and I you see
it's only one and obviously I can't
create groups but now that I've uploaded
now I can start creating a pipeline how
do I go about creating a pipeline I
always have to click on start and I can
read here some directions about it so
here's some background information on
how to create your own AC pipeline but
then I also have a limited selection so
not everything lights up because for
example array too fast that doesn't
light light up why is that because this
is for array files not for fast fuse box
so now I have some logic behind what is
available to me this pre-processing
section I can click on the section name
and I can read about what is it do after
I understand let's say I don't want to
do pre-processing I can skip it I can go
directly to anything I want let's just
do something that doesn't make sense
well let's say I want to select this one
after this one can I select bowtie - t I
can't right but I can select some other
things so if you can now try and play
around with this and tell us what
pipeline you're doing so by the way to
cancel a selection I just right click on
that button and then I can deselect it
and I can fix and use something else and
you can see that every time I make a
selection other things light up because
my options are going to be based on my
previous selection and the type of data
that I
your since nine now remember your name
well Rajesh what - did you just create
some rundown you know part just text
file or if you have fast few files and
wait two hours since random right really
good
so he'll any pipelines there on your end
yeah I'm just a second okay okay for
example like let's try and connect just
a second money cuz of cushion over here
hello hello just you have explained that
once again if I have a unknown gene said
so then I have to go to first offered
then to bowtie but if you were known
gene cell then I can directly go to more
time right if you want to map a lone
gene sir okay so I think I'm doing am
looking for the unknown genes in a non
ideal situation so first the upper this
pre-processing I should go to this
profile I start then cufflink of not
then more time yeah okay thank you you
create a pipeline that connects top hat
with ourself
top hat with arson zone top hat with
arson can you directly connected to
either of us our segments that are 7x
what can you connected to our cell no no
you can't put that okay so that why
let's talk about the largest why do you
think you can't connect top hat with
arson what do you think and what is our
sin do creates a table like sorry I
didn't - yes but to create an expression
table you need another step in between
right you don't just need to map you
also need to quantify how many reads
fell on that G so that's why you can't
connect directly just the mapping to the
table okay and let's speak about
measures of expression how with how this
table is created so there are several
approaches the first simplest approach
is so we want to estimate the expression
of the gene the simplest approach is to
just calculate number of reads which are
mapped to this position just number of
reads so bigger number of reads bigger
expression yep this measure is some kind
of bad imagine you have some short
transcript and
you have some very long-term screamed
and if you have same number of reads on
long n on short obviously short
transcript is more expressed than longer
one so we need to present process not
only number of counts but the length
length of the gene so we have two other
measures called fpkm and TPM so fpkm is
just counts normalized by the gene
length and you need to to look at your
data data you can look to your data in
two scales in linear scale and in
logarithmic scale and usually
logarithmic scale is used because it is
more convenient for for bioinformatics
so if you have a difference equal to one
in logarithmic scale it means that
actually there is a difference in two x
so let's look how expression table looks
we need to go to the output files then
to expression quantification and here we
have expression genes fpkm just open it
with how to open Excel drag it
okay here's our table so rows are jeans
here are some gene identification so
Ensemble IDs and columns are samples
here we have 11 samples samples does VL
contains 11 links and for each sample
and each gene we have a number F PKM a
bigger this number the more so the
better gene is expressed through just
huge table how many rows we have there
let's let's look at it something about
20,000 genes so let's return to the
presentation different cell line in our
example and one more thing why we should
do pre-processing let's compare let's
look at the right plot
let's compare fpkm so expression levels
when we do some standard pre-processing
in our cases 3 mimetic and PCR cleaning
and we and when we do not do any face
pre-processing and you can see that for
high gene expressions for higher values
of fpkm
we have some based distribution so we
see that FP cams of pre-processing
samples and not we process example does
not match so this line is just respond
to equal equal expressions and we see
that expressions of standard
pre-processing is actually lower than
when we do no pre-processing so
pre-processing is need to be done every
time you handle some
sometimes transcriptomics data so let's
take a little break just to understand
what we have done so we just created
pipeline which estimates expression from
row fast queue files so introduced plus
Q reads and output is the table for
further steps which we would we will
work only with this table so it's
important to understand how we get that
so if you have any questions please ask
now is everything cleared so far
now us questions
okay well let's quickly review so the
pipeline again the room look yeah hey it
isn't leading the question oh one sec
zero so let let us finish with the first
question right so the two pipelines that
we created were basic pre-processing
right so PCR clean and traumatic that
remove duplicates and remove adapters
then we moved on and we selected bowtie
to t which is mapping on transcriptome
and mapping on transcriptome what is the
transcriptome that is all of the
expressed genes so we did we are just
looking for genes we're not looking for
any real elements in the genome right
the genome contains many different
elements like just genes contains all
kinds of repeats and it contains all
kinds of non-coding areas we forget all
of that because we just want a simple
expression table so we say whatever is
in the file that specifies genes map all
the reach to those
locations in those areas and after that
we have position from position to
position and reads that Feldick right
and then we did the next step we did
quantification of now we have a bunch of
reads let's just put a number to it
right and that's how we got a table of
expression and then we press the end and
so as a result we got this table of
expressions that we just looked at as
IDs and then these are ensemble names
for genes and then in each column we
have a sample whatever is in that sample
is the number corresponding with the
expression of that gene does that answer
your question yeah so pipeline is a
function that creates an output the next
function takes this output not the
original one but this created one
process it does another thing passes it
on so it's just a way to pass on files
from one step to the next and each step
depends on what the previous that puts
out and that's the logic behind
connecting those pipelines together
because you have many different
alternatives for the same thing that do
something a little bit different it has
yeah like for
you have one sample you can't do
differential expression if you have many
samples you might want to do
differential expression right to
richness considerations are around the
number of files you upload and then each
previous step it will generate some
output so only certain things can work
with that output that everything else
yeah so here what what was the question
yeah letting it be high in the download
files there are many of sense when it's
unfiltered then the gene expression so
what exactly this unfiltered means okay
let us open this file and look at these
files okay here you see it's the same
table but some rows some genes are very
low expressed for example this gene is 0
almost in all samples and you see that
there are about 60,000 genes here so not
filtered just contain some genes that
are actually not expressed in our
samples and filtered is just when we
simply remove these genes which are very
low expressed in our samples we have to
only extract us this gene expression
text this is a filtered file right yep
okay thank you one more thing what Erica
Dixon when should we do that error
correction after the first
pre-processing there is one button error
correction actually what exactly means
is Khoa the first question and we'll
just show all of the output files
okay so what we have here is expression
genes in fpkm expression genes not
filtered expression genes expression
Aiza form is order I the point eisah
forms is a variation of the team but not
the exact gene and then we have the
mapping stats table so the mapping stats
table gives you how many reads one back
for example if you are mapping a human
sample to bacteria may be zero genes on
that right so that file will tell you
how many reads mapped on to this genome
that some technically but this is useful
information because sometimes for
example you have a human sample and you
expect that maybe there's a presence of
bacteria or a virus you might say okay
let me take this sample take the viral
genome and align it to the viral genome
may be something or what and so then you
can take this mapping that stable and
understand what happened okay and your
second question was
oh yeah when you run your pipeline there
are three ways that you wanted out right
this counts which is exactly how many
fountain that number is what we take
when there is fpkm
which is fragment from Orion for tilde P
right so that accounts for the gene
light and when there is CPM which is a
similar thing but a little bit different
yeah
you know yeah so error correction is
primarily used for older army seek files
that are pre Illumina era and for micro
arrays so microarray had a lot of errors
and then washed for example had their
own sequencer so there are a few other
sequencers not Illumina and they also
had a lot of errors and these were
technical errors so statistically you
could separate what is air from
biological variation so all of these
that's what they do it's useful in some
other cases where you need to get too
low frequency mutations for example or
you need to get to very specific
determination of isoforms if that's what
you're looking for you can consider
using some of these methods okay so
let's move on because now we got to the
table of expression and now okay one I
want to mention here that all of this
that we're learning is available online
for free you can download not download
you can go online and take these lessons
and it covers all of the basics it's not
exactly an interactive thing like this
but it's it covers all the bases okay
let's move the next steps and now about
machine learning and first we will speak
about unsupervised learning and what is
it in in this pipeline we use 11 samples
but actually we have 52 samples that's
52 cell lines and they are they are all
cancer cell lines and breast cancer cell
lines and we want to understand is there
any partition of these samples to some
groups which is biologically meaningful
for example our cancer cancer can be
divided in some groups which are for
example clinically different
or different in another aspects so
unsupervised analysis is when we have
many samples and we want to divide them
into some meaningful groups yeah and how
we can do that first method is called
PCA and just some simple example suppose
that we have only two genes in each
sample so if we have only two genes we
have only two numbers as associated with
each sample if we have two numbers we
can draw a point on the plane yep first
number is x-coordinate second visit
y-coordinate and we can look at these
points on the plane and see that these
points are located at one place and
these points are located in second place
and we see two groups but we have 20,000
genes so these 20,000 table is filtered
one more time and actually we have 7,000
genes so we have another table here I
will show you so we have 7,000 genes for
each sample and we can't visualize its
data because 7,000 dimensional is some
crazy thing but we can make projection
from these seven thousand dimensional
space to the plane and the main idea is
that not any projection is meaningful
for example let let's look at my phone
it's a three dimensional object and you
see two dimensional projection now and
now you see just some small surface and
you don't understand that this is
actually phone but if I will turn it
this way you will understand that this
phone so a PCA is a method of projection
the high dimensional data data to the
plane by maximizing variance or
the point so we see some we see a
maximal amount of information on this
display so it's just a method to
visualize the data let's create simple
pipeline for that
here we go to the unsupervised analysis
section click upload files here are here
we will upload expression table and it
is not so heavy so we we are not using
using SPL links and we just directly
upload the files so let's go to the
input files folder then select
unsupervised 7000 genes and then input
files and supervised seven thousands and
then cell cell lines expression data
input files yeah on supervised so
thousand
without marked judgment open it is
uploaded and then we press continue
start and then choose PC a troll and
here we have some default options click
save and then go to the end see you can
assign our Batory name to the pipeline
and then you can click run by pipeline
it won't take so much time so it is
running now and you can see the status
of the pipeline in section my pipelines
start it start at 0% if I will reload
its it is processing so we do not have
very much time prepared
and just do not wait which the time
let's go to the output folder I have
prepared yes in fact your pipeline will
not take that much time but your
explanation just not to waste free
minute so in output files here we have
unsupervised folder and we here we have
PCA 7609 file here is a PCA plot dot PDF
and if we open it we see that projection
from 7000 dimension space to the plane
so each point is a sample and he will
see some natural separation do what its
output of the pipeline we can yep we can
see how it is generated I have grated
pipeline several days ago
ah done you see that my plan is so this
PDF is generated by the pipeline let's
look at the screen we have here we have
a PDF yeah so we see separation into two
groups okay it looks exactly to the
presentation
but actually these fifty two samples are
divided into four clinical groups so we
have this division we have four cancer
types called luminol basil basil with
some kind of people- well the low and
normal life
yeah so we have input file we can go to
the folder the files and seed files
unsupervised 7,000 fees and here's a
file with marked Pacific's we can okay
you see it's not Excel but conceptually
this is important to understand right so
what is unsupervised unsupervised means
that we don't know anything about the
data
so somebody rajesh came to me with a
hard drive said here's a bunch of
samples tell me what's in what can you
see in there right so without asking any
more questions i just do an expression
table I do pca
i see some separation then i come back
to him and I say hey I see two groups
what could they be in he's saying oh
well actually when I created this I took
you know one from this person that
person maybe those are the three right
but now we can cheat because we already
know what the clinical subtypes are yep
and this is an additional level of
information that allows us to see
whether there's some relevance and those
known um oh okay so we see that each
sample is associated to the one of four
plat
basil normal like luminol and found in
low so it's just like previous table but
with one more cheating line so we we
have four loops and then we can upload
this file and recreate pipeline for the
PCA okay so let's try and do that what's
ok lets you do that yeah so you get the
feel for creating PCA tables again it's
PCA draw not just it's good trying to do
upload the one that's called mark so
okay then pchew drop you see we're now
just keep all the basic parameters the
same yeah later on
what are visually people yeah anything
so all of the machine learning section
works with tables they typically have to
be in txt format so they're tab
delimited files but save that dot txt
and write but that's not exactly true
that is in those parameters that you saw
you can select actually which one so in
the same table you can for example do it
by jeans or you can do it by samples I
can show you see all the way so you can
transpose and you can also you see the
number of PCs you can determine how many
you want to see in the drawing in the
figures I've actually PC and project not
not only on playing but on
three-dimensional space on
four-dimensional space and what is the
optimal one PC principal carnage
how many is the optimal number yeah okay
well let me answer this question in
output folder we have file called PC at
this point if you will open it I wanted
to open it in okay let let me
oh okay
here you see a line called variance
percent and here we see four first pcs
18 4 second is 12 4 6 and so on so this
number indicates how much information
this principal component contains so he
will see that first three principle
components contain 18 plus 29 30 36
percent of all information it's not so
big percent but if we will have some
less number of genes for example 10
genes we will see that 95 percent of all
information is usually contained in
first two principal components so the
general rule of thumb is 40 percent so
you want to kind of get close to 40
percent so here you get 36 percent so
the first three components is enough and
look at how much the fourth one adds to
you only 5% more so that's up to you and
you can look at the table and then
decide how many you want to draw so
there is a situation where I want to
include up to 80 percent right then I
can take the first step so in this case
up to the 19th a physical confident say
that again I couldn't understand exactly
how this morning if I want to explain
around 80 percent of my sample variation
then I still like and waffle if you just
want to do 18 1 8 or 88 0 18 18 yes you
can then instead of drawing a
two-dimensional plot you can just do a
one dimension and just do a bar chart
and that will be a good explanation of
your samples so for example if
samples divided into two perfect groups
and you just have some that have high
expression across all genes and some
that have very low expression across all
genes you can just plot that on a bar
graph you don't need a two-dimensional
scatter plot for that the one
dimensional spaces are aligned one
number and you can draw it by the bar
chart does that make sense
kind of fun so good question here you've
taken first three principal components
right pc-1 pc2 and threes three
two-dimensional plot for this okay let
let me what open one more time this PDF
we see plot PC 1 versus PC 2 then we
have second plus PC 1 versus PC free and
PC to PC free oh ok ok ok so there are
multiple individual parts okay so you
can actually draw free dimensional plot
but it is difficult to analyze ok ok if
you run PC on mark samples you will see
yeah please check if your pipeline
okay and here is another PDF and here we
see that one of the obvious groups is
actually some clinical group called
luminol and other other points are also
classified and but we do not see that in
the previous part so this is cheating
this separation okay so that's that is
about PCA it's just a method for
visualizing high dimensional data and
let's let's go to the next steps well so
let's quickly do a little exercise here
not an exercise that you have to do but
just to explain how this works we did
PCA of seven thousand genes do you
understand how we got to seven thousand
genes set seven thousand views seven
thousand do you know how we got from
original table to seven thousand genes
just feel to removed filter yeah so we
filter all the low expression that is
below some threshold but the question is
if we have so many thousands of genes is
it informative for what we're trying to
do or is it not informative okay so as
an example we will address that question
in the future part of this but as an
example we know there's a clinical panel
a clinical panel that contains 50 genes
or Pam 50 we can take those 50s and
massif I these samples or I do pca with
this the 50 genes so this is the output
of that table you can see that out of 50
we only have 35 because some of the 50
were not expressed at all and as a
result the classification actually is
not
so bad right so I mean you can see here
these groups better defined than if you
do the PCA for 7,000 T so why is that
well first of all because Pam fifty
genes were specifically chosen to help
us classify breast cancer samples that's
one of the reasons but the second reason
is because if you consider the biology
of these cells what accounts for
variation between these cells obviously
it's the different subtypes of cancer
but also other things right so there's
many different processes happening at
the same time and there's some variation
that actually doesn't depend on which
subtype of cancer these cells are in so
we have a lot of noise a lot of
information that's not useful for
classification it's just there but it's
not useful and so this is just a good
example to see how reducing the number
of samples gonna help or the number of
features can help us do understand
what's in the data but then the question
lies in how do we actually select those
genes that we want to look at and that's
something where we will address in the
supervisor section so 7,000 genes
contain much more information than 35
but they contain a lot of noise so
reducing number is good for C and the
other methods for unsupervised analysis
is called hierarchical clustering what
is the difference between PCA and this
procedure PCA is just a method of
visualizing theta and hierarchical
clustering is just an algorithm for
separating our set to the predefined
number of groups so let's let us create
the pipeline okay we start from the same
section upload same file not marked
then click start then select H last and
here we see some parameters which we
need to change let me wait until you did
everybody get to this point maybe he'll
do everybody get to this point as you
can see it's just one of the methods for
clustering there are other ones there
but say he'll did everybody get to this
point
okay so first change link age to word
not deed yeah so first change linkage to
Mars then we expect four clusters yep
we know that there are four groups it is
cheating but we know if you don't know
you can put arbitrary number here and
then you will we will see just several
minutes and then save and then go to the
end
then you can run it okay and as usually
not to wait until to finish okay and we
have folder in output files here are
called clustering seven thousand genes
and there are two PDFs way up yeah
Dixon you can show in the presentation
yeah you have to play let me show how
this works
yeah sorry see he'll we are putting you
on black screen here for a second and
perhaps just oh yeah that's fine let's
see how the string actually works both
that we have points on the plane and we
want to perform some clustering
procedure we can find two nearest points
yes your samples we said these are
samples and here we have two axis
actually we have seven thousand X's but
let us imagine that we have two teams I
just think if this is the PCA right this
your PCA picture and you've got the
samples on a plane just the idea we find
two nearest points then
we found we find two nearest points or
point witches or point which is nearest
to the group which is also which is
already marked here so this circle and
we see that these two points are the
nearest point so this point our distance
between this point and this group is
bigger than distance between these two
points and then we repeat this procedure
after we mark these pairs as clusters we
see that these points this point is to
say that yes you see that we follow
distances and by longer extending the
distance between points and we point the
cluster as a single Center select
nearest instance it can be distance
between two points or distance between
two already created clusters no it means
is other in that it's just another here
totally another idea
so you're just talking about there is a
different method of clustering right no
it's statistical based first we but it
is also lastly yeah but totally
different ideas and then we will race to
the situation then all points are marked
as one big cluster this process can be
visualized yes
here's the different types of metrics so
first is Euclidean metric is just what
you linear just simple distance to
points you but there are some another
just like Manhattan distance when you
calculate it's like lease and some other
and a linkage word dogs do td2 is a
distance between two clusters it is easy
to calculate distance between two points
but it's not obvious how to calculate
distance between two sets and linkage is
a just type of this distance what is the
type of distance between clusters let me
enable videos
the bottom
so in the meantime you can check if your
pipeline and he will see a dendrogram
what is Denver gram is a visualization
of the process of this agglomerative
clustering at each step we add more
clusters we yeah and the height of these
three is the rate of dissimilarity so
points at the zero level are very
similar and points at the top are
dissimilar so it's just visualization of
the process of joining clusters together
and on this then program we can specify
a number of clusters for example if we
want to clusters we can draw this
horizontal line and and do some car at
hops
so these line cuts are three into two
edges so this is the first faster on
this the second if we will grow line
here line intersects or edges and we
have four clusters and from this picture
we see that actually we have something
about four clusters here is the first
one here is the second one the third one
and visaphone so some natural division
by by distance so points from this
cluster are near points from this
cluster are near from this from this but
they are not near between these two
clusters as you see rate of
dissimilarity is fight
okay so it's about dendrogram and as I
said we have four types for clinical
types and let us do some practice I want
you to draw a general Ram with not
sample names at the leaves of the tree
but group names at the leaves so here we
have sample names and I want to you to
draw a trend at dendogram with group
names here so how can we do it lets us
open so before we actually do it do you
have any ideas on how to do it let us
look at the files starting right so
where would you put the Cruz
that we have well so we have the file
that has all of the gene expression data
right and on top of problems we have IDs
and yeah grows there are genes so now we
want to into what's displayed here is
the columns right so we use our column
names so how would we switch the column
names to be instead of sample names you
can use transpose oh so good idea good
idea but transpose will actually then
cluster genes right so we're 7,000 Leafs
instead of 52 those names are the first
row data set and we have another file
called marked let's open it and think
yeah okay and here we have two lines on
the first line is also the first life
line is leaf names for the credence
dendogram and how to make these names to
be live names what do you think question
to the audience say helix well if you
use this one it will still show the
first row right and what's the surface
so delete the first row in being
clustering all right congratulations you
won the first prize tonight all right
the first row and then do prospect but
that's not all because group swings
should be replaced two IEDs
so you need to remove first row and
rename group to ID and then yeah the
leader changed on you you want to do
that real quick and see if you get the
right output how to do right click on
two things the way you as always have to
press that ah how people work with okay
so you go to yeah unsupervised so again
where is this file this is under input
files on supervised 7,000 jeans
yeah yeah just upload this file and from
PC and I have done it several days to go
and I have pipeline for each age class
through classes and let's go here here
is a PDF
and here we see group names at the lips
so what do we see continue looking at
this tree can you explain what we see
yeah appears are all the luminal samples
are clustered together
exactly not only luminous but there are
two clusters mainly right is one cluster
and chlorine like and Basel are appear
to be clustered together along with the
normal light you can see that there
question together why white due to top 3
so this suprise for cloudy and the
subtrees for Basel so we do not look
only at the tree we can look at sub
trees they say that cloudy lows are
similar and Basel ones are similar and
they are dissimilar because their rate
of dissimilarity is about 218 so in
other words you can look at this and get
already some information just by looking
at the tree you can see like you said
that some cluster together some might
decorate it in two sub trees what other
information do we see here not exactly
so there seems to be a group of 4 basil
and the rest of the basil are separate
right so they don't all fall under there
so that's interesting right and it seems
like maybe those basil ones are actually
closer to normal way so that's if we
were really trying to study this data
set we will ask the question why right
another thing that I can point out is
that there seems to be an outlier a
single sample right here
right this luminol one I can't luminol
one so it actually helps probably for us
to put the two files where our sample
names which one are type names and then
see what's in those samples what's
special about those simple and so why
are we actually reviewing this because
in the next section we will learn how to
classify samples right so we will be
able to take out one of the samples and
see how these procedures machine
learning procedures will assign a single
sample to a specific subgroup okay so I
think we have finished with unsupervised
learning section so this asked question
about it before I summarize it no
questions okay so we studied
unsupervised learning it's when we have
a lot of samples and we do not know any
groups and we want to understand is
there any division to groups which makes
sense and we have two methods first
method is a principal component analysis
just to visualize and look at the data
and the second is dendrogram it's also
visualize and see what's happened but
some but you can cut the tree and get
exactly number of fasters so if you want
to get four clusters you can get four
clusters PC can't select clusters just
visualization and there are a lot of
other clustering methods how good
questions are how how do I know which
genes are responsible for this
clustering okay so
question we will answer that in just one
second London we had here so the
question here was is there a meaning to
how far apart the samples are on the PCA
right that was the question so we can
actually look really quick in the output
files and let's go to unsupervised and
let's go back to PCA plot so here we
have some dots right and the question is
whether there's a meaning for this
separation and let's take a look on
another on for example 50 in jeans
really quickly and look over here and we
can see here right so like we saw in the
dendogram some things are closer
together some things are farther apart
some things are even more far apart
right so there is some meaning to it but
we are only looking with our eyes so for
example if I look at this dot right here
what is the meaning that I can assign to
the distance it's not very clear the
dendogram the hierarchical clustering
actually helps me determine what might
be the significance by setting that
cutoff and doing it step by step and
putting them into these sub trees this
is the distance of the projection and it
it is not equal to the real distance in
high dimensional space it's very
important so objects which are really
far in high dimensional space can appear
very close in okay so okay and the
second question yes a second question
can you repeat it please so the second
question was how can we know why
different samples fall into different
clusters correct like can we
the genes that are responsible for the
separation yeah that's that's the
question
so now I'm on this yes there is a way to
do this it's actually fairly simple to
do it or you can do it in Excel we're
not going to cover this today but if you
go on the website and go to
transcriptomics - you will actually
learn how to do that in Excel and
tomorrow we will touch on another aspect
of the platform that it allows you to
download our scripts for many of these
methods and there is a way to modify
that our script - then give you the
separation not based on samples but
based on genes and then you will know
why the different samples separate based
on a number of genes the next section is
supervised analysis well what is
supervised analysis in unsupervised
analysis we had a samples and no groups
in supervised analysis we had we have
some amount of samples and each sample
is associated with with some group so
our samples are divided into groups and
then we have one more sample and we do
not know to which group it belongs so
the aim of supervised analysis is to
train a model which will learn on trip
on the training set the set which is the
set of samples which are marked and then
to mate to make some predictions on new
unclassified samples is it clear okay so
yeah
and let's think about some fundamental
problems the first problem is following
imagine we have a algorithm classifier
which need to tune 7000 coefficients in
in the workflow so we have 52 samples
and 7000 coefficients how do you think
is it possible to tune 7,000 numbers
having only 52 samples now it's not
possible you will race to overfitting so
this classifier can say it will it will
tune parameters for each even for a
meaningful data set so 7000 coefficients
is a very big number for 50 to 52
samples but there are some algorithms
which can work in the cases when
dimensionality of the space is much
greater than the number of samples so we
have 7,000 genes and 53 samples some
algorithms like stepwells limit linear
discriminant discriminant analysis and
random forests can work with this
situation on other algorithms like SVM
support vector machine like K nearest
neighbors and a lot of other algorithms
can can't work if number of features is
greater than number of samples and one
more thing we have curse of
dimensionality it is is a principal when
if we have a data set with a really big
number of features any supervised
analysis algorithm will work badly so
big number of features is really bad
these raises to the idea that we need to
perform some feature selection we should
select some small number of genes from
7,000 7,000 is a really big number we
want 1015 we want number of features to
be comparable with number of samples and
first approach is to use that step Wiles
Lda let us see how it works so stepwise
Lda is not only a way of classification
it performs future selection - so let's
go to supervise the analysis section let
us upload files and we have here input
files then folder supervise 7,000 genes
and here we have two files brain and
test so train is a samples which are
marked so each sample is associated with
one of the groups and test file is just
file with samples with no groups and our
algorithm will do some predictions on
test dataset
does that make sense so far yeah I can
show them in Excel if you want so let me
do this it's important what happens
we can do anything
PC is a method to visualize I
dimensional data no no no no no
projection is if we have full selecting
feature is just selecting this side on
this side but I but I can rotate it this
way this way this way and it's not a
feature selection is selection of linear
combinations so not only x axis but X
plus 2y
all right reacts yes PCA is principal
component right and those components are
accesses right that actually represents
many different combinations of things so
that's what PCA does it chooses the best
combination so that explains the
majority of the data here we're actually
looking at selecting individual genes
long the visual features and yeah so
when we do stepwise lva and we will see
it right now if we do like you said
seven thousand genes right the major
question is we want to get to you know
if we have 52 samples something like
under 50 genes and we don't really have
a simple way to do it we have to do
compare many many many to many things
and that's what's that points actually
so here is our train set the sample
names and associated group names and and
here is a basic set now group names and
that wise Lda will make made predictions
it will to parameters of train set and
make with the
addictions on desks but actually before
you close this it's important to
understand that the training is not
included in the test so if you have a
total of 52 you can take let's say 20
and then you will have 27 left or I mean
32 left and reading so if you have if
the test inside or the test contains
training that's going to be bad for you
so we have 52 samples and here we'll see
reads weeks 14 samples can be choose
anything real or real problems you do
not separate the data to train and test
sets we had 52 samples and we know
groups for each of them so I have just
artificially created this data set so
imagine that the algorithm is like a box
and the Box knows to recognize what this
is so what this is we first need to tell
it what it is right so we need to show
it many pictures of cats right then I
will start learning that this is a cat
so but in real life scenario we will
have a number of samples that we do know
something about and a number of samples
that we don't know anything about and
the job is to train it and then see how
it recognizes in our case we created
this artificial example so that we
already know the answer but we can just
see whether the algorithm does what we
think it's attribute so I know the
answers to these samples and you know
and we will see okay so I have uploaded
sample is that right so how is it that
training the data set then well no so
the
training does have groups
it does have group names the training
one but the training one doesn't contain
a number of samples in our case we chose
14 samples remove them from the whole
table and now we just have you know 36
samples or 38 samples in the training
sample in the test set so we give all
the information to the train deficits
along with what they are and how they
are classified and then keep them away
from the test answer yeah and then we
move both files okay thanks
load continued start then we go to
stepwise LD so just pause you real quick
again if you want to remember what this
is right there explanation yeah and we
need to modify this parameter so ab10
and then 9u oh it's what this some
threshold for this elderly it's some so
it is difficult statistical procedures
and to explain these 32 words it's some
so actually if you mouse over the I will
give you a short explanation this is
kids I can say that if this number is
very small then some small number of
genes will be selected the less is
number or less is this value as genes
will be selected
and then click Save
this pipeline will take about five six
seven minutes so let us look at the
output not wait it is in output files
folder in supervised folder and in spld
a subfolder here we have file called as
well do a prediction test we can open it
and each assigned classes to the samples
from the test dedicated dataset and as I
said I know correct answers and from
these 14 samples there's one wrong
prediction this one so this sample is
actually normal like and all other
predictions are red so can we open the
dendogram with the sample names yeah
so right so in this case actually it's
important to just kind of consider that
these methods don't tell you how exactly
they arrived at this conclusion there
are some algorithm that doesn't and you
can understand the algorithm but it
doesn't tell you all it's because of you
know these considerations so it's a
little bit more difficult to interpret
sometimes that would put to the same but
there's a way to check right so this was
18 use it it's difficult to say why the
cell do if you said it's this sample to
answer some things that go into this is
obviously you know what we gave it so
how well the training data set
represents what we have in the test but
also some fine tuning of parameters
sometimes printable playing around with
things and doing them multiple times
might produce different results and if
you're really trying to solve the
problem that's the way to go okay that's
the folder and see what we have some
prediction statistics for example we
here here we have confusing matrix for
the training dataset classifier was
evaluated for sample from the training
that it made a set after tuning
procedure and we see that it raises to
100% accuracy on training dataset well
there's no confusing metrics on test
dataset because I have not
specified correct classes so okay so
it's not confusing metrics and you can
say that it's obvious that after
training on that training data set
algorithm will give a 100% correct
answer to the training that we pay to
set but that's not true in general case
because if you want to get 100 100
percent participation on training data
set you will raise to overfitting so you
have noise in your training data and if
you will tune parameters to have 100
percent accuracy you will forget about
some other samples which exist so 100
percent on training dataset is not our
aim just simple classification and 14
okay and the third file here called svl
da feature
officience and it contains some genes
which are selected as the most
informative ones so i have putted these
genes this 15 genes are located in in
input files folder annotation subfolder
here we have 15 genes just the general
to everyone you have to press the green
one pipeline button as we don't they
will say prepared and if it's just
prepared it's not running okay so we
have a question that is being done in
Tilton's you know what exactly is ahaha
how is this analysis being done words
like is there a way to get that you know
are poor or anything from from this the
background information yep you can get
the our code so you can access to to the
pipeline folder click download pipeline
files and here we have s vld our PAC
Donzi I will return to this question
some minutes later okay right now it's
only our we have so many different types
of analyses use different code like some
are written in C or something like that
so we didn't do everything because our
next session tomorrow is going to be
focused on heart and so after stepwise
Lda we have a number of we have 15 genes
which are some they are informated so we
have we had seven thousands and now we
have only 15 now
now after feature selection we can apply
some other algorithm statistical to have
some magical numbers
okay now I will go to the presentation
okay here we're gonna put you on black
screen here for a second but if I will
select you what this place it will not
close so now we can apply another
classification method because now number
of features is less than number of
samples for example we can apply support
vector machine classification what is it
suppose we have two groups and two jeans
just doing circles and red squares on
the plane and we want to train train a
classifier to predict to which class
belongs to which class belongs new
object and for these sets we can go a
line which separates these two classes
and classification rule will be very
easy if a new sample is at the left side
of this line then it is a green circle
and if it's right side it's a great
green circle and if it's on the right
it's a red square but this line can be
rotated so we don't have an unique line
we have some a huge number of lines but
for each line we can draw two parallel
lines which are intersecting with with
the nearest object from the both groups
okay so so just some parallel lines in
both directions and we
see that we have parameter D these width
of this of the suit yeah cap yeah and
the support vector machine
classification is to draw a line which
maximizes this gap length
yep width so the greater is this crap
get with the battery's classification I
think it's just okay and in real life
okay let's return to this example in
this example there exists a line which
separates two groups but you in real
life there can be situations like an
outliers well there is no such lines in
this case we can draw any line which
separates green group from the it's not
like it's the curve yeah so in this case
we can penalize wrong decisions so these
two red squares and this one green
circle will be penalized yeah and now we
have sample which is which we want to
predict its class and if this sample is
at left of our line it is green circle
and you right it's red we're okay
and let's let us prepare a pipeline so
now we're doing some practice right
before practice let us create a SVM
pipeline we go to the supervisor
analysis section you will upload files
but not that
Reavers once here we have folders
supervised 7,000 genes but I want
supervised 15 genes though 15 selected
genes and a blows train and test files
we continue then start you we have SVM
kernel type actually if kernel type is
linear SVM will draw a line if kernel
type is radial then some more more
complicated shapes are alone not only
lines work actually these are lines in
higher dimensions but not lines
projection and we have cost parameter C
it's just efficient for penalties and
scale places yes or no
usually what penalty as I showed there
exist some situations where we can't
draw
ideally separating line yet and in these
cases we penalize wrong bad point so
this red square will be penalized so for
example if you expect if you expect it
to be perfectly separated you might keep
that friend or low if or I mean high
right now because you don't want to
accept it so you want to give a lot of
penalty for a wrong assignment of route
but if you want to if you expect there
to be a lot of overlap you might make it
look so we minimize penalty and maximize
width of the gap comes
yeah if you go into their program it's a
penalty efficient so it's a number which
is which is coefficient for penalties so
kind of the Sun usually these penalty is
you do some experiments in first
experiment you put it one in seconds if
it's five seven and I choose the best
one
so you can't look at the data and say
that's the best value of this
coefficient is 17
you need to this is called
cross-validation when you perform
multiple experiments to estimate the
best value of this parameter let's
select radial kernel type it's a mod
it's it's the best kernel type for SVM
usually it is used and go to the end
don't forget run and for SVM results are
perfect we can go to SVM folder SVM
results for test set open it showing in
the file that you have it's again in the
output files under supervised analysis
and then you can just look to the screen
just like the same file but here this
sample is correctly classified so no
errors on test so SVM is a very powerful
classification but we need to select
feature before running SVM if we will
run SVM on 7,000 genes first it will
take some very very long time very very
long is and but if we will wait infinite
time it will give some not meaningful
results okay and this is about SVM and
so and now little so the practice is
intended to demonstrate what is really
going on right because right now we're
speaking very hypothetical things
there's some algorithm you train it you
give it some data right like what does
it do so let's pretend we are the
algorithm and let's try and do this
ourselves so if you can open we have
this table of fifteen genes
it's the 15 genes that we got from
stepwise OVA if you can go to the output
files for the input books or sour input
files under unsupervised 15 genes and
open that in Excel okay so again what do
we see here you see 15 genes and their
expression values by sample and we have
52 samples okay so now our task is to
use expression values and try and see if
we can create groups so the easiest way
to look at a lot of numbers at the same
time as the key part right so you guys
know how to do a heat map in itself if
you just select all come on
and then you go into conditional
formatting and you do color scales and
let's assign bread to be the highest
[Music]
conditional formatting but instead of
there we go okay so now you don't have
this table now let's make it smaller at
the bottom you have okay and Wow you can
see some
okay so yeah can you see some pattern in
your for example I can tell you what
what pattern you might be looking for so
you definitely see the top two or three
genes right that are consistently green
they're consistently low expression
except for some that are not white some
of them are white also at the bottom you
see about three that are major Li red
but sometimes green right so now you see
this little but if you quickly go and
just let's make this okay so if I narrow
this down I can now start moving things
around right so for example I can take
this one and I can move it next to this
one because both of these at the top
right they are white
okay so it's not only think about the
algorithm doing this what is it doing
it's doing the type of feature selection
I choose what to look at that I think is
informative and I'm putting those two
together because I think they are alike
right so if I continuously do this step
by step I take one I'll move it I take
another one I'm moving eventually I did
and I honestly did this I'm not cheating
here I get something like this right so
the same heat map but now you can see
what do I see over here I can see that
these samples all of these samples over
here clustered together why because all
the top ones are tween and all the
bottoms one already right and these are
not like that and in fact if you
remember our dendogram it kind of did
the same thing we have two major groups
all all luminol and the rest but I also
see some strange things right so if I
look through here like for example this
looks strange
everybody's green and this one's white
or here I've got this guy who's an
outlier to all kind of strange looking
right even though it's Munna so I start
seeing that this actually does represent
the full dataset if you remember the
clustering you did with 7,000 genes
it gave us HEC to 201 as an outlier
right or 2 and 2 so I think we are
seeing the same thing so this is just to
illustrate what the algorithm actually
does to try and determine something yeah
okay and this these facts raising us to
the fact that feature selection can be
really good even for unsupervised
learning now if I will run PCA and
hierarchical clustering on 15 genes not
on 7,000 as I've done before but on 15 I
will see better results
let us look you I will run you see on
these 15 genes I will see perfect visual
separation of these moves yep
they are much better separated than in
previous experiments or your article
clustering we also see much better tree
structure actually you see luminol is
also divided into some into two groups
it's not it's not random effect
Lu you know is sometimes classified as
luminal a and luminal B and we see them
so the main idea is that feature
selection a
positive thing not only for supervised
analysis but for unsupervised analysis
to feature selection is very good thing
and you can around these two pipelines
as in previous runs simply by selecting
files from all supervisors 5015 means
folder that we selected from 7,000
dreams now from QT okay and that's all
these methods that we've done up until
now are covered in transcriptomics one
two and three and transcriptomics one
actually goes through the first part
that we did which is from raw files to
gene expression paper transcriptomics 2
deals with basic statistics behind
finding groups and how to do pca and
interpret this year the transcriptomics
3 lesson or course is focused on machine
learning so how to do many different
machine learning things not just the
ones that we cover today but also
k-means clustering and other techniques
with examples are there any questions
okay so finally the last section that we
want to cover today is there go ahead
okay so what does all of this mean right
so we found some 15 genes we found some
groups how can we find the biology
behind what we thought okay and first
idea is to transform some ugly ensembl
IDs to some meaningful meaningful
information for that we have utilities
section in the platform you can select
it upload file with 15 indent IDs of
these genes this file is located at
input files annotation 15 genes load it
press Continue
start what
then we create the pipeline start then
we go to the annotation job
save it with defaults parameters and go
to the end okay it's running let us see
results they are located in output files
post-processing and file is called 15
genes annotated
so what we'll wait some and in the
meantime as we wait it's actually this
happens sometimes on the platform some
of you have seen it that this just keeps
loading sometimes it happens and it's
not a big deal you just reload you go to
my pipelines you find the last prepared
pipeline and you just click start and it
will run
okay in this file we have a lot of
information about about our genes just
you stable with any public available
information and the main thing we will
use today is gene sign bone because here
we see two genes DCM and EP cam which
are known to be some cancer markers so
what you make
EP km and you can read about it this
article okay we hope so let's just
demonstrate how to find all this right
so first of all in this table right you
see the name will have gene description
okay and you can look what does this
gene do and then you go through the
domain right so typically how do people
do this
Edward do you have any idea how people
are gonna take genes from ensembl now so
typically you go to your database called
David and you plug in your net list of
genes and it takes like 15 minutes and
you get all of these different out and
what it does is it goes through a
database of known genes and what
pathways that involve them and tries to
understand how it relates to their
function and so that's what you get here
is gene description is just about
individual gene and then geo domain and
category and multiple domains they talk
about multiple types of activity that
these genes are involved in and so these
two that we selected f10 and ECM so you
see 4dc annexes Daquan you see gene
description
right here it says the core so I can go
over here and you see the corn right I
can actually use that name search
through literature and find a bunch of
papers that talk about this June and in
this case we can see that these two are
important gene signatures for metastatic
spreading breast cancer for example or
the other one is in the tumor
microenvironment so that's just to
explain how from this basic table of
ensembl ids we can get to something
meaningful something that we can try and
interpret in terms of what people know
about functional T okay and the last
thing is there another approach for a
piece of selection now suppose that we
have only two samples the two groups two
groups and some samples in both groups
and for each gene we have expressions in
first group and in the second group yeah
and we can try to compare mean
expression levels in two groups now we
can do that yeah first of all this
technique is called differential
expression analysis we find genes which
are for example low expressed in the
second group and high expressed in the
first group which characteristics can be
calculated first characteristic is the
difference between mean expression
levels just we have mean expression
level in the first group and in the
second group and we can take difference
and this difference is called fold
change is and actually this value is
presented in logarithmic school so full
change equal to one means difference in
expression levels in two times okay
second value indicates indicates
statistical significance of these of
this difference this value is called
p-value and this is a probability of
observing such or bigger difference if
we assume there that there is no
difference so low p-values indicates big
difference between win expression levels
so if we have p-value 10 power minus 16
minus 16 that this indicates that this
gene is actually low expressed in the
first group and I expecting or in worse
situations but in our cases we have a
huge number of genes and suppose let us
let me show some example suppose that we
are tossing a coin 10 times and we see
we observe 10 heads so after that any
normal person will say that this point
is not normal but if we will take own
population of the earth and everyone
will toss the coin 10 times there will
be a really many people with ten hats
series this called multiple testing
problem and p-values need to be adjusted
in order to solve this problem
so we have p-value and adjusted p-value
which is also called phone discovery
rate FBR our Q value sometimes okay and
also you should pay attention at low
expression low low expressive genes
because comparing zero with zero point
zero zero zero
one is not a good idea it's good raise
two big p-values but actually there is
no difference okay and so to demonstrate
this again we can just manually look
back in our table and see what our table
shows us yeah so if we look at our
fifteen gene table right so we already
noticed here that there is a difference
let's take two small groups crowding
well and normal like if we just take
those two we can separate this into a
new table and now look at this map of
colors you can easily detect okay so
this red and this green right there is
some difference the green is low the red
is high so these are pretty high these
are pretty low that means that there is
a difference in expression so what if I
take this gene so I can just take this
gene and select all of these values and
to demonstrate I can create a simple
chart that indeed shows me that
difference very clearly so now I can
take a couple just to compare them and I
get three examples some of them good and
some of them not very good so these blue
bars are not very good because they
correspond to load stress genes as I
said for example you will see just line
of zero values and it is not very good
to compare 0 with 0 okay and how to
apply differential expression analysis
in our platform we just start as at the
beginning of the workshop creating
pipeline of
expression table and then we add one
more job called H R or deceptive or any
arbitrary jumper from this section but
usually HR and decide to are used they
are the best solutions for that and ah
no meaning nice
oh so then this is almost the end it
actually and since everybody else can
see the screen we can just turn this
around
okay let me show is just how result in
case it looks like this in beef
expression folder for example this HR
here we see gene named logarithmic fault
change log CPM is a characteristic mean
expression level so if it is low we
shouldn't look at this mean and we have
p-value and adjusted p-value false
discovery rate and we can solve this
table by FDR and the first for example
15 genes are best genes for separating
these two groups this they they have
really extremely small value that means
that we have really big difference in
expression levels okay and after
creating this table we can perform a
pathway enrichment analysis what is this
we have some pathways some known
pathways and we have top 100 genes from
differential expression amorites and we
want to understand are these 100 genes
presented in some known pathways for
that we have not we standard tool for
this is david but this is all generation
2 because this method does not look at
level of differential expression it's it
just looks to the gene mates no not
looking evaluates for change and so on
and if we will take into consideration
level of differential expression for
example whole change we can run human
so it's just new generation pathway
enrichment analysis methods in just
difficult statistics here's a slide how
to run it
platform and each results - very
beautiful and meaningful pictures to
post processing eat any of them here's
some pathways and here's a table
indicating p-value for each for each
pathway so this pathway is
let's in first group and ready
[Music]
okay yeah so man is just to say that we
selected a number of projects like this
the one is that we wanted a which is a
cell line project another one is a PBX
attack patient dividing of different
then does the same thing goes to the
foundation of classification and there's
also a dataset from TCGA
that also contains many many different
cancer types for many patients and all
of these are on the website so you can
just like think download they now
performs an analysis to interpret it and
see what - yeah so we didn't have enough
time to do two more practice assignments
which is PCA using differential
expression the only one who was trying
and applied your freedom trying to send
home if you look this is the survey yes
so this one is server that - - by if you
just read so on though edu website yeah
this way you'll have projects here and
so the project are curated data sets
have some breakdown of the policies
thanks on many courses they actually go
through the courses are step-by-step
tutorials the what's there and yeah the
last part of it is our scripts
yeah there's going to be data and if you
want to practice on this
we did some homework you have hands-on
directory and here are some files for
example in folder - there is a mixture
of T C V and unique examples and your
task is to run PCA or
hierarchical clustering and see the
separation questions like I have only
know that I've analyzed previously the
two periods up two different samples I
don't know the word sample it's related
I just like to know what since
differentially not differentially level
of expression of different genes right I
am NOT comparing with one with others
I'd like to just know what are the genes
x over expressed water pigeons down
express so I will do they on supervised
analysis rate also when you have only
two samples and you wanna see genes that
are highly expressed on bone spurs yes
there is no analysis to do there you
just give a threshold for example you
look at at the very top so you nice them
from top to bottom right and you see
what is the threshold for example you
want to see a hundred top it's pretty
key right then you select the first okay
and those will be their highly expressed
gene no so but that should be done in
excellent or is that if you want I'll
straightforward test but the main idea
you sort them from
is there any anything filter can during
this pipeline can I give any threshold
so that it will directly give me the
status
well that produces the take over
expression but then if you want to
reduce the table of expression to
something manageable right you saw that
the expression table contains 61 Eugene
yeses you need 60,000 there do you need
a smaller number I need a smaller amount
which is a very high level of expression
now but then I got only 17,000 in the
next day uploaded to door 2 samples
that's only 17,000 genes so within the
17,000 genes so I like to know which
genes are more expressed or less
expressed can you analyze in this
utilities or I'll do manually in this
excel file in case of one sample it's
you can another analyzed it's just by
Excel if more than two samples and it
will be difficult I have two samples
actually I'm just practicing I upload
two samples I got 17,000 genes per km
values now I like to just know which
genes and overexpressed in these two
samples which are lower down regulated
run differential expression analysis
methods but for one sample statistical
methods there's no specific review
something
okay thank you
[Music]
why thank you guys thank you bye